the French police is under attack for
what critics say are heavy-handed
tactics and Prejudice Paris is once
again mainly calm nearly two weeks after
the killing of 17 year old Knight LM by
a police officer
but the six nights of rioting that
followed that are seemingly part of a
vicious cycle people in the suburbs
believe they are victims of racism and
brutality the police say they are at an
increasing risk of violence
all that anger is fueled by political
speeches which say the problem is the
police the police and only the police
more than 270 police buildings were
damaged during rioting across France
such as this one in banyola near Paris
where police Brigadier Linda Kebab works
she grew up as the daughter of Algerian
immigrants in a suburb of Leon
these are cool places that need a lot of
money but they don't give police money
either they dismantled police who were
engaged with the suburbs I come from a
pool Suburban I don't accept the
political speech about people who come
from there but at the same time I am a
police officer I am French and I know
I'm lucky to be in the Democracy we have
democracy
others from outside the force have shown
a light on these complexities
journalist Valentine genre went
undercover as a police officer for six
months he said he witnessed racism but
also intolerable working conditions
they're working with a population that
hates them and the second highest rate
of suicides in France is among police
officers but the most urgent thing is to
clean up the police a lot of them
shouldn't be doing the job
for French minorities it's simple they
say they are treated differently and
that it cost not LM his life
how can people tolerate overworked
police officers killing a child when we
have former president Nicolas Sarkozy
convicted of corruption and no one ever
pointed a gun at him the corruption of a
former president is far more serious
than a child without a driving license
the EU commission has criticized the
French government for its handling of
the riots and for racial profiling of
suspects there's little sign of that
changing
this boarded up and fire damaged police
station is a result not only of the
killing of nael but of the long-standing
problems between the police and people
in the suburbs solving those problems if
they even can be solved also looks like
taking a very long time
Polaris Al Jazeera manually on the
outskirts of Paris